hey guys it's evan i'm here at the soho
conference in vancouver british columbia
and i've just learned about an awesome
new program called dell for
entrepreneurs which provides tons of
resources to help new and established
entrepreneurs grow their businesses so
i'm going to try to corner the president
of dell canada get his take on it and
see what the program is all about and
how can help entrepreneurs
so i've heard this great program that
you've launched del for entrepreneurs
tell me a little bit about it
well evan we launched dell for
entrepreneurs here in canada about a
month ago the program is really centered
around providing entrepreneurs a
platform for enhancing their businesses
and for driving growth and it has a
foundation of four principles one it's
about enhancing engagement and knowledge
around entrepreneurship and how to build
the business two it's about gaining
access to technology what that looks
like what it should be number three it's
around capital providing access to
capital understanding what the different
forms of that are and how they can
utilize it to leverage their business
and then the last one is as you know
very very important access to networks
of individuals that really help a
company move from being that startup
phase to the next phase of growth why
did you want to bring it to canada
what's the incentive behind i got i got
a couple of key areas here number one
i'm a canadian born and raised in canada
i'm passionate about canada and i have
children and my children need businesses
to go into to start up themselves to
work at
entrepreneurs and smbs across canada
represent over half the employment base
i think entrepreneurs really are the
growth engine for canada as an economy
over 500 000 entrepreneurs started
businesses in the last couple of years
and as we look at the future of this
country there's nothing more important
in my mind than entrepreneurs taking it
into the market building their
businesses and really helping canada be
a place that is in the future the place
everyone wants to live i love the
passion coming out but it's great it's
awesome
where does that passion for
entrepreneurship come from so obviously
you're at a huge company dell yeah how
does someone like you as a you know
president for the the company for the
country
how are you still passionate
entrepreneurship where does that come
from hey yeah i do work for dell we're a
very large global company a hundred over
a hundred thousand employees but at the
core and essence of our business is an
entrepreneurial spirit that was
initiated by our founder michael in his
dorm room he started this business and
now it services markets of over 180
countries around the globe
that entrepreneurial spirit is embedded
in everything we do each and every day
we actually have in my performance plan
taking risk as being one of the
components against which i get measured
so
i'm doing
i'm doing okay
but as you look at taking risks that's
really the essence of what entrepreneurs
do each and every day they wake up they
see an opportunity see an area of the
market that's not being served and they
put it all on the line to execute and so
when you look at entrepreneurship that
drives me it drives me for internal
projects that we execute on it drives me
in the way that we engage with
entrepreneurs as young customers of ours
that then grow into very big customers a
couple of really cool examples on that
you may have heard of a company called
salesforce.com
they enable entrepreneurs by effectively
allowing them to get a whole customer
relationship management system at the
push of a button going online getting
that on a web dell was with them at the
founding and we're with them now
providing the infrastructure in the back
end there's another company called
twitter twitter was with dell when they
were a very small startup and now we
work in providing the entire back-end
infrastructure of twitter and the third
one is dropbox we want our files and our
information to be safe and secure and we
work with dropbox to get that done so
the companies that we engage with today
that start from the genesis the kernel
of an idea that then grow and prosper in
the future we want to be with them today
and we know we can scale with them as
they drive growth what's the website and
what do i do when i get hey this is
one of the easiest things that you can
do today it is go on www.dell.ca
backslash entrepreneurs if you can't
spell entrepreneurs then that's probably
an area you should focus on first but go
to that website there we have a number
of areas there to again give you
knowledge give you access to networks uh
help you understand how we can engage
with your capital and then obviously in
today's interconnected world technology
is a part of everything whether it's
engaging with your suppliers engaging
with your customers or helping you go
global with your product your service
your idea so who is this for who should
sign up
evan i would say that any entrepreneur
that is involved in enhancing their
knowledge about how they can really
accelerate their business should start
up for those organizations that are at
that front-end stage of their growth
sign up get on the site
get some knowledge and learning from
other entrepreneurs through the
information that we provided that
education piece is really critical for
those organizations that have
developed their business to the point
where maybe they've received that first
round of funding or they're on the verge
of hyper growth and they're really
utilizing technology to get there we
have an amazing program called the
founders 50 and the founders 50 is a
global program where each six months we
take in
50 organizations we provide them
concierge level service access to the
dell venture fund access to the
engineers within dell and the networks
that we have to really help them get
into that hyper growth stage and so i
think from that end of those that are in
the hyper growth area to those that are
just at the start of their business they
can get great information by going onto
the dell website and accessing the dell
for entrepreneurs program thanks so much
fantastic you're awesome thanks evan
really appreciate it have a good day
everybody